Oh John you said it yourself
there's always a price to pay
[Music]
doc tober I want to try and cram some
more spooky sort of stuff into the month
before it's over so uh I got my hands on
the DC animated film Constantine city of
demons um this one was one I have been
aware of it it kind of fallen off my
radar but then it popped up as something
that I could get through through Netflix
DVD yes I do still use that I might be
the only one but um I got it I watched
it and it's really good first of all
we've got matt ryan back as constantine
he really is taking ownership of this
role to an impressive degree it's really
it's really fun to see you know somebody
just own it to the degree that he does
and it if anyone has been following his
version of Constantine whether it was
through the TV show that got a season
his appearances on legends of tomorrow
his appearance in Justice League dark or
whatever not only is it super consistent
this actually ties into some specific
stuff that has been brought up over time
I mean I'll just say it if you ever
wondered exactly what happened in
Newcastle which has been referenced
pretty much since Matt Ryan took the
part well you can find out what happened
in Newcastle and it's not pretty but I
mean that in the best way this was
really really good and so aside from
from Matt Ryan coming back and doing the
voice first of all it's just great voice
work across the board on this the
animation is solid and I think it's I'm
really hesitant to say that the
animation quality is getting better
again because I've said because I've
been I've been following DC animated
movies long time and the animation
quality did dip a fair bit
in the last few years and by animation
quality what I mean is how much
characters jump from pose to pose like
you lose the fluidity because they're
doing fewer frames of animation because
doing more would be more expensive and
that had dipped in recent years I didn't
feel that nearly as much here I don't
want to go so far as to say that the
animation quality is actually higher
here than elsewhere I honestly think
that just the design and the feel of
this world
and these settings just kind of covers
that weakness a bit more and I mean if
only for a lack of point of reference
like I always really notice when say
Superman and Batman's animations are not
fluid because I've seen fluid animation
for these characters not so much
Constantine and definitely not for you
know these kinds of monsters and demons
and whatnot I'm used to seeing those in
more I'd you know things like anime and
you know until my say anime I mean like
original vampire hunter D wicked city
you know these these things that had a
tendency to cut a few corners but you
got away with it because well you were
seeing something you didn't see
elsewhere and I think this might have
that going for it so again I don't want
to say with certainty that the animation
quality is better but it feels better I
think that's that's that's an offshoot
of the of the production design of it
though and story-wise he is brought in
by a friend of his chas who did appear I
think pretty sure that was him who was
in the in the Constantine series but
he's a recurring character in most
incarnations of Constantine Chas brings
Constantine in after not having even
spoken to him for a very long time
because if you know anything about John
Constantine you know that being his
friend is that's just inviting trouble
so he seeks Constantine's help because
his daughter is in a coma and Chas is
suspecting that there's something else
at play and John very cool
covers that yeah there absolutely is and
what unfolds from there I'm not gonna
lay too much about I am gonna talk some
spoilers at the very end but I'll give
you a warning before I get there but it
involves going to Los Angeles it
involves a heck of a lot of demons it
involves the usual mixture of religious
points of reference that I love that
Constantine does so you've got demons
that are very biblical nature you ever
consist of voodoo you've got ads Tech
lore you've got all this stuff and it's
it's also one of the things I like about
something like Hellboy basically saying
every religion and every superstition is
valid and they can be used they even be
used against each other like I kind of
love that as a whole general premise and
and how things work I'm pretty sure yeah
pretty sure this was rated R this one
feels more appropriately rated R than
usually happens with the DC animated now
it's still you know it's still rated R
in some of the I was gonna say
superficial in some of the sophomoric
ways that things tend to be rated R
there's a little bit more swearing
there's a lot more blood but honestly
the whole feel of the whole of the story
as a whole feels more mature I don't
mean mature in you know the ramped up
sexuality and and violence way I mean
mature in that this is about adult
characters dealing with you know
heightened
demon but at the same time very adult
problems and and a big part of that has
to do with there's no easy out to this
there aren't clear-cut oh here's what we
do and then everything will be fine
there are lasting consequences to things
there are sacrifices that have to be
made to get to even have a shot at a
positive result and there's no guarantee
that it's even gonna work even if you do
pay the price
so there's with all of that it's it's
the much lettuce degree of certain
of success and the basic guarantee that
success will still come at a cost
so that and that vibe permeates the
whole movie and that is just a much more
mature feel to have then you usually get
in the DC animated movies and I really
appreciated that quite a lot even aside
from Matt Ryan the voice work is great
the demons especially there's this one
demon that like I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna miss words there were certain
parts of this that did turn my stomach a
little bit not because it's like so
graphic that I couldn't watch at it but
I'm like I'm watching it and it's and
it's just it's not that it's super
graphic it's just framed and set and
moodily set up and just the right way
and it evokes just this little oh and
like the concepts of some of the stuff
that you see particularly comes because
there's extended sequences of demons
torturing humans and this could have
been completely gratuitous this could
have been completely yeah yeah yeah
you're just doing this because you can
cuz you got an r-rating boy but it is
done really well and it adds again to
the sense of nobody wins you can't win
not really
and it really builds that up amazingly
well and there are oh I was gonna say
something else now I'm gonna say that
for spoilers I really I really only have
one substantive complaint about this and
that is that there is one character
there's a I'm not gonna explain quite
what their deal is but basically there's
a body hopping character who gets
introduced about midway through and you
know communicates with John through a
couple of different bodies and then has
an extended period in the body of a
woman who is really over sexualized like
and it wouldn't bother me so much if
like that vibe had come off even a
little
and any of the other bodies and like I
get that you know the the other bodies
were Mahler there was one that was a kid
definitely don't do it with that but I'm
just saying that it feels like oh now
that this being is possessing a woman
let's get stupid over-the-top sexy with
it I'm like why why what was the point
of that and if it was so extreme and
there have been so basically zero hints
of that as a character element prior to
that that it really that felt gratuitous
like the torture scenes didn't feel
gratuitous but this felt fortuitous and
it kind of annoyed me and actually it's
compounded because later on there's um
there's a moment with that character in
a male body sort of gives Constantinus
light kiss and Constantine kind of uh
and that annoyed me because Constantine
in the comics is canonically bisexual
and like I'm waiting I'm not actively
annoyed yet but I am still kind of
waiting for that to be properly
confirmed in you know the matt ryan
version of Constantine and that to not
only not get it get a confirmation but
to have like him sort of revile a little
bit that it just but it just felt like a
no homo bro no homo moment and I'm like
come on now to be fair I'm probably
putting more weight on that than it's
deserved because like think the the when
the characters possess the man that's
being possessed that that plans to kiss
on custody he's also old and you know
constant is like you know I don't go for
the wizened thing and so like you can
make the argument that he's actually
turned off because this person is so old
and kissed him but if that's what was
meant I wish somebody in the room some
right or somebody had stopped and gone
you know guys this could be interpreted
badly in terms of you know how this
character is in the [ __ ] and you know it
matters to some people that you know
there's this element to his character
and what we're doing with this gag it
could be read as negating that maybe
don't do it so either they I was gonna
say either they did it on purpose if
they didn't buddy I think probably
didn't do it on purpose they did it
without they and I hate running into
this because it annoys me so much and
probably more so than it should but they
they had a joke and they didn't think
through the implications of it and that
just annoyed me because again John
Constantine if he doesn't get confirmed
as bisexual in the fourth season of
legends of tomorrow that that will
actively start annoying me but I'm yeah
that that ignore me because I'm still
kind of waiting on it with this guy but
that's that's really kind of it that's
why from these moments tied to this one
body jumping character who I think is
not an otherwise bad character on the
concepts kind of interesting with what's
going on with that person but like these
couple of things that happen just mmm
but that's really it like I said the the
the weight and the darkness of it and
it's not like you know I'm Rudy and
damaged you know the world is dark like
no it's just you look around and go man
there was not a lot of light in the
world is there it just feels like bad
and it delivers it really well I'm gonna
get into the spoilers a little bit cuz I
want to talk specifically about the
ending and about some of the things that
it made me feel about the ending so
that's your that's your last warning I
recommend this especially if you like
the character of Constantine go see it
getting into spoilers I choked up at the
end of this movie because there's the
sacrifice that happens so
on the off chance that you haven't seen
the movie yet and you're watching the
spoilers because you don't intend to see
the movie or you're just curious you
don't care bus clothes whatever they are
able to save Chaz's daughter but
Constantine engages a spell that
requires a sacrifice requires a
sacrifice of love and what that means is
he funneled all the love that his
daughter and his daughter's mother had
for him for Chaz into the spell and used
it up which means their love for him is
gone and they don't remember him the
mother just remembers some one-night
stand doesn't remember who was with and
his daughter has never known her father
so that got me initially and then
there's another moment after that where
Constantine tells them you know that
wasn't enough I had to feed more into
this spell than just that and I had
defeated us your love for me at the end
of this conversation you're not gonna
remember me because I had to feed that
into this spell too and the loneliness
of that that really hit me and it's
something of it's something about
because Constantine is when done right
he's a really well-balanced character
because he is you know he's got a
swagger and he's got a cockiness he's
got a devil-may-care facade but he bears
so much guilt for things both that he's
done and things that he was just in in
the
proximity of and he feels some
responsibility for and to see someone
like that willingly isolate themselves
further and yeah you know he can make an
argument he did it you know to save this
girl's life but I don't think that
that's all that was going on he also did
it to punish himself he knew that he had
this guy in his life who loved him and I
don't think he thought he deserved that
and that's not to say he didn't want it
but he didn't not only did he sacrifice
Chaz's love for it for him he did not
sacrifice his love for Chaz which means
he is going to remember his best friend
who now has no idea who he is
and he can never reconnect with and he
can never talk to again he did this
sacrifice of love in a way to make it as
brutal on himself as possible and I have
been watching these animated DC movies
for a long time and I don't think I had
any that choked me up before I've had
you know some get me you know really
excited some give me energized I've had
some creep me out like in a good way but
I don't I don't think I've gotten you
know that lump in the throat from one of
these before so I mean I yeah I wouldn't
have called that my son wouldn't I
called it with this one I mean I was
looking forward to this but I did not
expect to be touched by this
it's a really really good film with a
couple of flaws that I really wish
weren't there but it's really good I
think honestly it might be the best
piece of Constantine media outside of
the comics to date yeah so if this is a
character that intrigues you at all or
you know one who you've you've liked
from the comics and have really been
waiting for them to do right watch this
I think this does it right now wrap up
on that note so Constantine city of
demons what are your thoughts on it
whatever they are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it a whole
bunch of stuff to do because there's
buttons and there's links including one
to my patreon if you're feeling generous
but you know what if you're not don't
sweat it too much because remember folks
you are the council and I just run the
meetings until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]